you've seen the prequels sequels and
spin-offs but before you see the prequel
sequel hybrid reboot revisit the trike
whoa that started it all the x-men
trilogy in a world where people cheer
for superheroes like the Fantastic Four
the Avengers and spider-man those same
people will inexplicably hate the x-men
get out of my bar freak because for some
reason there's a difference between
superpowers and mutant powers a gas suit
up for director Bryan Singer's first two
x-men films that proved comic-book
movies can be awesome and director Brett
Ratner's the last stand
that proved comic-book movies can
totally suck balls
look recoil as the spoiled hack
douchebag takes the reigns of the
beloved franchise only to kill off your
favorite characters leave out your
favorite characters and depower your
favorite characters I had to all while
completely butchering the Phoenix saga a
storyline so iconic even the cartoon did
it justice Scott please do it I can't
but don't worry they're sending
Wolverine back in time to make sure
Brett Ratner never happened maybe
Professor X the Dumbledore of Xavier
school for Witchcraft and Wizardry
it's basically ITT Tech for weirdos suit
up with his best students the x-men
leather fetish versions of the popular
comic book characters
there's Wolverine a man with a
mysterious past
that must have included a lot of
steroids Cyclops a bratty crybaby who's
only there to solve Wolverines game
stay away Frank
whoa who gets the crappy no touching
part of her powers but not flight or
super strange storm who can control the
variations of the weather but not her
bad African accent at least I've chosen
a side Hank how all the students the
school stays open gambit and Jean Grae
whose Phoenix energy is released through
the power of stairs
they'll team up against Magneto a
Holocaust survivor who basically becomes
Hitler we care a walking internet meme
of the gentle [ __ ] and his Navi psychic
mistake who wait is she naked
she's totally naked right man somebody
got to paint that on her boobs to make
them you know blues I am so lonely
watches all mutant kind must band
together to defeat evil government
officials how to prove that mutants are
dangerous which they totally are
ah geez
starring Melisandre oculus rift twigs
Sookie
Ron Paul Logan Valjean
Rebecca religion Harry blues and Timur
the x-men trilogy so they couldn't find
room for gambit psylocke or cable but
they managed to fit in horn man
slim-fast and the bad hugger ah be sure
to subscribe for more honest trailers
turn down for what what's wrong with
your face I demand a trial by combat
you must construct additional pylons I
love pizza so much it's time to
digitated a duel